نعم السيد الرئيس أه في وقت سابق اليوم
أه الدكتور ريدفيلد أكد أنه يبدو
وكأنه
نوفمبر ديسمبر
سيكون بالإمكان
توزيع الجرعات الأولى ولكن بعد ذلك قال إن
اللقاح لعامة الناس
لن يكون متاحًا على الأرجح حتى
الصيف المقبل وربما حتى أوائل
الخريف  أنت مرتاح في ذلك الوقت ، لا
أعتقد أنه ارتكب خطأ عندما قال
إنها مجرد
معلومات غير صحيحة
واتصلت به ولم يخبرني بذلك وأعتقد
أنه حصل على الرسالة ربما مرتبكًا ربما
قيل بشكل غير صحيح لا نحن
جاهز للانطلاق فورًا
حيث يتم الإعلان عن اللقاح وقد
يتم الإعلان عنه في أكتوبر
بعد أكتوبر بقليل
ولكن آه بمجرد أن نذهب نحن جاهزون آه
كما تعلمون فيزر يجعل هذا الأمر
يخاطرون ماليًا هائلاً
وهم  إنهم
ينفقون بلايين الدولارات على
صنع هذا اللقاح بالفعل وهم في مرحلة
يصنعونه فيها بالفعل
لأنهم يشعرون
بثقة كبيرة فيما يتعلق بالنتائج التي
سيعلنون عنها.  نتائج الوريث قريبًا إلى حد ما
واه لا ، أه هذه معلومات غير صحيحة ،
لقد كان واضحًا جدًا في الطريقة ، حسنًا ،
أعتقد ذلك ولكن لا أعتقد
أنه يعني أنني لا أعتقد أنه عندما قال
ذلك ،
أعتقد أنه كان مرتبكًا.  أخبرك فقط
أننا مستعدون للذهاب بمجرد
حدوث اللقاح ،
لذا متى تريد رؤيته متاحًا ،
ما هو الجدول الزمني الذي سأقوله ،
نعم سنبدأ في توزيعه على
الفور
قريبًا جدًا ، أعني ذلك
حقًا للعامة  علنًا عندما نذهب فورًا ،
لا نتطلع إلى
قول جي في غضون ستة أشهر ،
سنبدأ في إعطائها لعامة الناس لا
نريد أن نذهب فورًا لا ، لقد كان
بيانًا غير صحيح ، لقد رأيت البيان الذي
اتصلت به أنا  قال ماذا قصدت بذلك
وأعتقد أنه ارتكب خطأ
للتو ، لقد أخطأ للتو أعتقد أنه
أساء فهم السؤال على الأرجح